i think his convictions about ukraine  and um  you know the reality of russians  russia's capability to you know continue  um to grind away at ukrainian resistance  i i don't know whether that's been  shaken yet  i think he's in a frame of mind in which  he doesn't believe he can afford to lose  so the stakes are quite high in this  phase in in the east of ukraine  as you know ukraine's military with  support you know from the west  continues to resist with a great deal of  courage and and tenacity and as  president zielinski continues to  demonstrate really remarkable leadership  and resolve as well  but i i don't think this means that you  know putin is is deterred at this point  because he staked so much  on the choice that he made to launch  this invasion  that i think he's convinced right now  that doubling down  still will enable him to make progress